he was the hotel manager who sheltered
refugees during the Rwandan Genocide and
Paul recessa bagina gained Fame for his
heroism he went on to push for increased
freedoms in Rwanda and that put him at
odds with those in power in 2020 he was
convicted on a terrorism charge and this
past March the 69 year old was released
from prison a Toronto filmmaker was
given exclusive access to document that
Mike trolley reports
and here he is Paul coming back to his
house for the first time since August 27
2020. it was a private moment for the
recessa bagina family after 939 days of
captivity as a political prisoner in
Rwanda Paul rusesa bagina was now free
two and a half years of waiting yeah it
was incredible it's uh I'm still I'm
still in in disbelief I still wake up in
the morning hoping that this is actually
real the only Outsider allowed into the
family's Inner Circle was Toronto
filmmaker Wayne Abbott who captured
rusevina's first public comments on his
ordeal
at the given time I was a dead person
but I never give an opportunity to those
people
see that I had given up to see that I
was weak
because the very day you give them that
opportunity
you are the loser
[Music]
you might recognize recessive beginner
as the hero of the 1994 Rwandan Genocide
after the movie Hotel Rwanda was
released he became a vocal critic of
President Paul kagami who has been
accused by groups like Amnesty
International of stifling freedom of
speech in 2020 while living in
self-imposed Exile rusessa bagina says
he was drugged kidnapped and brought
back to Rwanda to stand trial on
terrorism charges
the changing Trend over the last few
years is that it's not terrorist groups
that are kidnapping these people in hell
and and holding them it's actual
authoritarian governments
his subsequent conviction was condemned
by the International Community almost
immediately recessa begina's children
began working with the bring our
family's home campaign to pressure the
U.S government to use its influence to
help the wrongfully detained in
mid-march a deal was reached and Russia
said begin it was on a plane home with
orders from the U.S state Department to
lay low for now
he's a man with a big heart and he
speaks the truth
um
and so I can't see him being quiet
um and as some of the family members
told me they said Paul kagami made the
biggest mistake in letting their father
out from a Hotel Rwanda to political
prisoner Wanda rusesa bagina will have a
story to tell Mike trillet Global News
Toronto